Mau apparently, and I don't know if this is true, allegedly,
I've not looked into it. Allegedly, Mau messaged a woman of color
and asked her to write racial slurs on her chest. Disgusting.
Disgusting alleged behavior, but it is alleged. That's true.
Obviously, Yeah. I mean, who would do that? Disgusting.
Did that Did that actually happen? If it did happen, then she
did do it and she played into it pretty hard. That's all. I mean,
if it did, you're absolutely disgusting. I just want you to know
that. I just want you to know that. You just laughed. She just
broke. I won. She just broke and laughed. I won. I
Are you good?
You actually lost your mind.
Oh yeah. Hold on. Can we look at this again? Let me look at this
again. Hello. Who this?
Omar. What's up? Your audio just cut out immediately the second
you joined. Oh. Oh no.
This is horrific. Am I good You're good now. What's up? How's
it Uh, yeah. This guy's crazy, dude. This I don't even know if
people covered this cuz it was kind of like hidden away. I don't
know if a lot of people knew about this, but he basically wanted
to prove that he's making a ton of money and he's getting offered
he's getting an offer as chief something in San Francisco or
in maybe Portland, like some Seattle somewhere in like the West
Coast. And it's like, brother, if you're getting an offer to
be like chief technical something at some company and you get
165k a year, no, no, no, no. Not to live in those cities. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. And that was my response to this.
I thought it was a little
I don't know if this is too much of a derail, but he's been going
around botting everyone that's been on him. Go look look at these
comments if you care. Some of these are
like they're obviously bots. I don't know what the he's like.
I don't know if he thinks he's slick or whatever, but it's like
so obvious. It's so It's deranged, dude. This guy's
Enjoy your double bed, Batty boy.
Wow. Yeah, I don't know what this could possibly be.
Why? Wait, hold on. Were you covering him in this? Why were you
Why are you getting these comments? No, I mean, I've been I've
been covering him. Uh I mean, it's on all all the videos. So
you can go to like the newest one on my channel. Um like the
one that was posted today. It's in there as well. He uh he's
he's not doing this just to me as well. He is he's doing this
to Quean. He's doing this to
Oh, this is way more obvious. Yeah, this is way more obvious.
Wild that Purple Perry Gaming is tight with Morau who messages
17-year-old disabled girl. Yeah, this is way more
She's not even disabled. I'm pretty sure she was able. Mentally
disabled.
Able. Okay. Oh, I a little harder to argue with that one. I guess
Perry had 3,000 viewers. Oh, yeah. I had like um I had like uh
1500 yesterday. It was crazy. Oh, wild, huh?
But this is on Aiden's channel as well.
it's on Cleman's channel, I've been told. I haven't checked Cleman's,
though. So,
bizarre. So, you you believe it's uh Paragon, Star-based, whatever,
going around and botting comments on all your videos and stuff?
Yeah, I mean, I I I would assume there's literally nobody else
I could think of that would be doing this other than him. He's
like super There's also Let me see if I can send you this. I'm
pretty sure he's going to make like a video on all of us or something.
It's so
Yeah, I'll send you this. So, this is in Do you know who Spinal
BJ is?
Kind of. Yeah, kind of. Yeah, he's been talking magic in that
guy's server. So,
he So, Paragon's been talking in Spinal BJ's server. Did he not
think of the optics of that or not at all? I don't know. I mean,
his whole shtick is like we need to protect the kids, but he's
spuring in like a lollycon server. So, I'm not exactly
sure what exactly he's thinking there. But if you look at the
last sentence, he's like he said he's looking for graphic designers
and ed uh editors.
So he might be making an evil video.
He uh he DM'd me on Twitter um and he was like um
he said something like he was like you need to cover you need
to talk about this. And he sent me like uh the address, the full
name and like some other and I was like why the would I cover
this? Why who do you think why why are you sending me this? It
was very odd. I didn't really understand uh I guess the point
of it all. Very odd
Very strange. Very very strange. Okay. Are we ready to go on
this call now?
Yeah. Go ahead. It's your stream. You got it. You're You're like
a
Uhhuh. Yeah. I'm like a professional for sure. I really have
my my head screwed on, right? You know, definitely doing making
no mistake
there. All right. Anyway, we go. We go. We go. at first. Shut
up. But you're such a You're so fool yourself, dude. I'm not
I'm not I'm not doing this for content right now. Just trust
my plan for a sec. You're going to see what I'm doing. He already
said yes. Star did not know this was being recorded. You'll be
able to tell pretty quickly. But yeah, just if that matters at
all. Oh, Perry recorded this in OBS with uh his overlay on and
stuff, didn't he? I'm getting annoyed. I heard you said
Okay. All right. All right. I'm not You take everything so personally.
Well, you are actually talking you're talking to me. Jeez. Yeah,
but it has nothing to do something against you. You were going
to say it's something to do with you. I heard I heard you. Okay.
No, I said yo, what's up? Okay, guys. So, here's the deal. Uh,
I have a appointment later. Oh, this is like clearly him. Oh,
boy. With a detective. I'm not comfortable at all with this situation.
And for me, it looks like you guys are protecting this kitty
cat freak. So, you either wrap this up
and sort your out. Wait, who am I? I don't know. You guys got
this freak that is like texting women. He wants to them and he
wants to them and all this Yo, disavow. And frankly,
you guys got kids around.
crazy books. I've already I've already informed you Do I have
around? What kids do I have What kids do I have? I don't know.
I don't know. The thing is is that you just there's at least
this one. I don't Well, the thing is that it's it's not between
me and you guys anymore. I'm kind of I'm tapping out. Like I'm
I've already moved forward with having a call later today. Well,
you realize you're you're engaged in defamation per se, right?
I uh I consulted with a lawyer uh and by claiming that I I'm
harboring miners in my server publicly when this is verifiably
untrue. Uh so Oh, I don't Well, verify it with the authorities,
not with me. That's not Yeah, that that's that's the plan. The
guys like I I informed you that you know I'm not comfortable
with this information coming out. I was trying to You were comfortable
with it. You were comfortable with it. She said to me, "Use my
discretion." Well, yeah. To I I told you I'm not sure if this
is being recorded,
but you know, like tell inform the others that involved what
they need to not publicly disseminate this information. So,
the thing is that you've already you've already forced my hand.
I I'm already going forward with this. Wait, for your hand to
do what? Starbase, talk to me here. We had we had any opportunity
to work this out. Force your hand to do what?
Oh, I don't know. You guys call me all these weird allegations
going around. I never I never
I don't know. But you guys like it's I'm hearing all this stuff.
I think you
on one hand on one hand you're making claims that we're wait
the [__] up. On one hand on one hand you're making
claims that we're doing things like harboring kids or calling
you a and then when I ask when or what kids you say I don't know
if you are. So why are you saying that I am if you don't know?
I told you guys all about I mean what mind am I harboring?
I don't I mean
it it I don't recognize the voice. It seems colder than when
Paragon still thought he had a shot with lab. I don't know what's
making his voice his voice is like the same to me. It's like
it's obvious on his phone or like a different mic or something
but it it does seem like the same from what I I can hear the
nasal tone around here guys. Oh, this guy had a minor. Oh, there's
three minor. Wait, wait, wait. So, what does that do? I hear
that that
he wants to like [__] people and he has this fetish
for for [__] black women and it's Wait, how how am
Wait, this isn't about you, is it? Uh, no, he is talking about
me. This all Okay, this is about you because of me.
So, this is uh this has to do with Mau apparently, and I don't
know if this is
I've not looked into it. Allegedly, Mal
messaged a woman of color and asked her to write racial slurs
on her chest. Disgusting. Disgusting alleged behavior. But it
is alleged. That's true. Obviously. Yeah. I mean, who would do
that? Disgusting.
Did that Did that actually happen?
Um, if it did happen, then she did do it and she played into
it pretty hard. That's all. I mean, if it did, you're absolutely
disgusting. I just want you to know that. I just want you to
know that. Listen, man. You're the one who like BPD women. Okay.
I don't know what to tell
You're in favorable company. Let's just put it that way. I need
Okay, hold on. I'm uh trying to
I think this is not transparent. I don't know if I have a transparent
thing here, which is kind of rough. Hold
No, it's not. God damn it. Oh, that's not even working at all.
Okay, cool. Someone send me the dancing desi gift. How am I How
am I accountable? How am How am I How am I accountable for
you guys? How am I How am I How am I
I don't trust you guys. I don't know. You guys sort it out. Starbase,
it's really weird. Can I Can I say something? Can you hear me
out? I think it's really weird that you have an issue with me
for telling someone else to get miners out of his server. The
stream you're referencing was me
you brought it up. You brought it up. I didn't record you. I
literally never recorded you. You diss you I mean it it I mean
you under under under under this was established by the Supreme
Court right in a case of recording a lot of neighborhoods other
consent get a lawyer and sort it out with my lawyer I don't care
I already have one or you actually want to do that well I mean
the thing is I for me it's just I'm talking to a detective I'm
not even sure I have to do anything
what what crime do you think's been committed by either of us
I don't know I that's that's not for me to determine Okay. Well,
the detective might have you put on like a involuntary mental
health Okay. Okay. Okay. Have fun, guys. So, yeah, this is fun,
too. Send me your contact me again.
Okay. Well, that's great. Okay, dude. I did the the defamation
per se line was good, right? Um I guess I Oh, did you guys get
uh Discord back by the way?
Dude, this is uh this call is
goofy as I didn't even realize it was about you, but did you
guys get Discord back? Okay, got it. All right. Yeah, he's I
don't know if he did this when he was uh you know with with you
during the whole like uh you know, but he's very very very like
he's really into trying to like strongarm. I've realized it's
very like He is a little bit. Yeah, he like privacy struck my
channel.
There it is. Yeah. My my little game theory is he I think in
my head, right, he he thought that he got your channel removed.
Uh which is why he had this like hate. He was like, "We got to
really find out why JTO got his removed cuz he was going to try
to do some like weird vindication
like paragon vindication from like an alt account, I think."
Oh, I see. Wait, did he talk about that? Like some I never saw
him talk about that. Was he like, "Oh, we need to know the Now
that I think about it, I feel like he was like
I Yeah, I know. I feel like that had a lot to do Yeah,
I think that had a lot to do with um or sorry, I think I remember
him asking me about it and not believing it when I was like,
"Oh, this is what happened." He was like, "That doesn't make
any sense." And everybody else was like, "No, no, no. This is
this totally makes sense. This what are you talking about? It
doesn't make sense. Like, this rationale makes total sense."
man. It's uh it's crazy that this guy I'm sure he'll keep making
alts, too. Probably try to stay away from VCs for a while, but
I'm I'm positive he'll keep making
Yeah, exactly. Fest. Yeah, the Yeah. Oh, man.
Things just clicking into position. So, he used to when I'd say
like, oh, it was this Darius VOD and all this, he would go, "No,
no, no. Couldn't have been that. Couldn't have been that. Couldn't
have been that." Yeah. I I think he was trying to do trying to
lead up into some like Paragon vindication is my uh my little
theory. Okay. Well, ba a base. We uh
love this guy. Okay. I'm not sure. Like, honestly, there's not
a whole lot to this other than these things. Like, we can we
can keep going through it. I don't think I'm going to watch all
of these. Oh,
they got uh they've got a little bit more. I've got more. Oh,
he just kept he kept like seething about Amumu all over the place
apparently.
Hold on. Let's pull more of these logs. Look, I don't care about
the ban. Ban me for any reason. Although I'm happy to be chill
and interact with your members politely, but if you keep company
like that in the there alongside the victims, which he has jacked
off to, then it makes a lot of sense why Willy Mack didn't take
you seriously. The Amumu guy is a freak.
Okay. Seething. Seething. Lots of seething. Uh, what else here?
Also, I just want to say the Amumu stuff in Roger, I have no
issue with Amumu. I like Amumu. I'm not trying to, you know,
start beef or whatever. Um, but that really long message Amumu
sent where he's like, "Don't message my girl." Oh, when it turned
out Zoe was like sending Paragon nudes the entire time is so
funny. That's so stupid.
I didn't see that. I did not see that. I did not see that. You
pulled it up on stream. What do you mean you did see that? Sorry.
I mean I didn't see it. Sorry. I didn't I obviously would have
pulled it up on stream. I mean
I didn't see
I didn't see it when um when this came back up. Like I haven't
seen it again.
Oh, okay. No. Yeah. I mean, obviously in retrospect, I'm fine
with Amumu. I don't think Amumu did anything particularly wrong.
I It was a bit cringe, but I just think that's hilarious. Like,
don't don't message my girl when she's like sending nudes to
other guys. Man, it should have been it should have been so obvious
that this was who it was.
He's a top Jtock officer. There was some big drama where he was
coercing the baby peach girl for her Destiny tape.
That's maybe a little more that's a little more neutral and like
not making giving it away, but just like his obsession out of
nowhere with people when he'd like always been banned from my
community. Technically, Jason is when he decided to switch alts,
nobody was really thinking or talking about him, so he went relatively
under the radar,
Yeah. I would have thought that Starbase was there while Paragon
was there. He might have been doing both at the same time to
be honest. No, it was in February. the moment he stopped talking
on uh on Paragon and stopped posting on Twitter on Paragon. He
started posting on Starbased like like the day basically
the month really. But you Yeah, you know what I mean. It's uh
he switched like no more Paragon fully switched to Starbased.
Okay.
Uh hold on here.
Sorry, I'm trying to get my
music going again. Okay. Oh, I would have thought there was overlap
there. I would have thought there was overlap for sure. Are you
sure you checked every There might be. There might be. I I I
don't know. I haven't checked. I'm I'm paring information that
other people have said to be fair.
Okay. He changed his account name to Starbase. It was originally
a different name. He has other personas he can inhabit because
he's aware that he's a weirdo. I think that's more what it is.
Telling his stream today how JTO swept for Destiny so he could
get himself opt to manipulating Lav and Zoey girl. Showed me
he has a promising career ahead of him as a Gillain Maxwell type.
while you're out there just
walking the streets at night. That's a weird com. That's like
a un I don't understand that comment in multiple ways. But interesting.
Uh Jtock scared all the good women away after the blonde horror.
So the remaining are beat AF.
Zoe's there. Uh that's weird. These are all just weird comments.
I don't think anybody left. Oh, except Seven. Apparently apparently
Seven had a donation to Chudstream where she was said I was manipulative.
I don't know what that's about. Uh I don't even need to talk
to her about it. I just I literally don't know what that's about.
I would want to know, but I also like I have no I don't need
to like pressure her to know. Don't really care.
I'm not totally sure what's up.
Yeah, I I just don't know what's up there. I don't know what
I did to upset
Yeah, she ended up something she donated something that ended
up being a copy pasta. People thought it was funny
did that to every guy. I saw him bring on Discord for DJ.
I don't know what this is.
It's an image. Uh-oh. Strike though. This reignites my skits
theory that JP lies about the what got him banned. While this
strike is a completely invalid claim, this is one of the few
cases where I've seen the harassment reason psyched by cited
by YouTube. BRB, you need to ponder my orb.
See, that's what I'm that's what I'm thinking. Harassment. Who
who could you possibly be harassing? You know, who did you bring
on stream four times? and and you know all that like I I am like
90% sure he was building up to like a like some sort of like
Paragon
uh redemption arc or something of the sort. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, is
this a do move? Dude, does Discord just automatically like translate
things into QuickTime movies like QuickTime videos?
Cuz like sometimes I go to like drag Discord videos onto my stream
and they're like move files and I have to wait and upload a clip.
Discord hates. And yeah, it's it's really weird with file types.
keep keep going. Keep pulling screenshots on. Dude, let's
Hi, Paragon. Wait, I want to guess how it was known. I didn't
h want to hide things from Queman, so I sent donuts from the
same PayPal after all the weird Destiny stuff.
Okay, so Quimman knew about this and was hiding it the whole
time. Very
Yeah, true. This is almost as bad as
like some form of like I don't know, you know, I don't No, I
don't. I I literally But Me neither. Me neither. Yeah. What does
this guy expect? Like Queenman's going through his donos and
checking the PayPal. Like is this guy What the I feel like I
would notice. Maybe not the email being the same, but if the
name was the same, I'd probably notice. I think I have some understanding.
Malo is mad. JTO stole his thing. Wait, what's Mau's thing? And
what did I steal? Don't actually tell me. No, I don't think I
did. No, I don't think I did. Technically, I was Star Bash before
Paragon. This is my OG account, but I made my other account when
I was streaming in 2019. Okay, hold on. Looking more more stuff
here.
The Hi, Paragon thing. Uh-huh. You hid the bird, Wigga. Don't
play Koi now. Oh, yeah. He did hide the bird. He like hid the
bird from everybody. And he hid the bird when he's like on calls.
That's the most annoying thing when he was on the call.
Yeah. Well, that's his RZ. Okay. The pom pom riz is his only
RZ. Okay. He He could by himself when he's playing Do you have
the Lav DMs on hand?
I might.
Well, let me send you might have all of these.
Oh, let me send these to you. The Lav DMs and and Dude, uh I
I probably have I think I have my streaming PC when this all
happened. So, I probably do have it all in my downloads folder
somewhere
It's an MP4, so you should be able to drag and drop. There's
audio. Mute the audio. I don't think the audio matters. Have
a thread called skin in the game. Uh oh. What is this? Oh, I
have like all of the I have like all of the Zoey Paragon DMs,
actually. Uhoh. Hold on. These are the lab DMs. dude. They're
so funny.
JTO is doing you dirty. I think I've read these on stream before,
but these are the lab DMs. So, he's trying to manipulate Lav
and Zoe to fight with each other, weirdly.
Yeah, he DM'd them both at the same time and was saying the other
person like lost and that they won. It's so bizarre. Sure. Hold
on. Hold on. I should acknowledge that he does the Rimmerald
RZ as well. Okay. He's got he's got both
Oh my god. I Bro, I'm
Don't DM me on Discord right now. Okay, if you're Just don't
DM me on Discord.
Don't do it. You're DMing me right now. Stop. Just stop. I gotta
I gotta focus.
God damn it. Hold on. Give me two seconds. Answer a DM. I'm so
sorry.
You're good, man. Hi, chat. Hi, Smile.
What's up?
What's with this JTO Kermit the Frog bit? This is a very uh
who made him do this? Why is he doing this? Can someone explain
this to me?
Are you an individualist or collectivist? I have never heard
either of those two words ever in my life. So I I could not begin
to explain to you
How much do you charge for babysitting?
His voice sounds similar to Kermit the Frogs. Well, that's just
rude. That's just evil. What the hell?
Okay, I answered DMs. Okay, we're back to this. My god. Yeah,
my voice is like kind of nasely. So, Kermit the Frog.
Oh, okay. I have like a gay voice, right? I've been told I have
a gay
Uh, I don't think so. I don't know what that means. I don't know
what that means to have a gay voice. How do you have a gay voice?
I have a very I I've been told I have a very gaycoded voice.
I thought the JTO community loved Paragon. I think people loved
the content around Paragon,
but most people were willing to admit after a while, especially
once he came in and was like I actually sent this I sent her
a picture of my
to do harm. I think once that happened, it was like, "Oh, we
this guy is psychotic. This guy's like out of his completely
out of his mind." Like we Oh. Oh. Oh. All the jokes are not funny
anymore. Okay. Holy [__]
Holy [__] Okay. Hold on. Jaytock is doing you dirty
right now. He has no idea what actually happened. Maybe mention
how unhinged his grope reviewers are going. Lav, you're hot.
And if you know you're hotter, taking down the pics is an optics
W. Steven and her is a ruse. We were flirting before Steven noticed
her. And why would he send the DM about her skin to her if they
were Oh, right. Paragon thinks he's like involved. He thinks
like the streamers are constantly involving him. He like thinks
like Destiny was like trying to with him by messaging these girls
or something. It's very crazy the way his works. Okay. The way
his like mind works very broken, very deranged, very it's it's
bizarre. Okay. You beat spin boy. Good job.
I heard you bullied him. Are you in DG Discord or no? Yeah, because
I up in compsai Lauo. What's up?
What's up? What? Oh, I didn't say anything.
Oh, this there's audio in the video. There's audio in the video.
Yeah, there's audio in the video. My Why do you need Hold on.
I've never seen him like this with his tail between his legs.
I don't even see Compsai. Uh, try to browse channel. Try the
browse channel things at the top. It's careful. Cake's domain
though. Be careful. Lol. Rip Spinboy. I was pom pun. I missed
it.
Oh god.
Uh, what was it like? Can you describe a little, please? It would
have been so cathartic. Maybe Jay is uncomfortable focusing on
women. That's not you. Oh my god. Why did he say, "Who are you
flirting or fighting with?" He's slimming you. Queen. No. J also
implies it. Jay said, "What is your name?" And he cut off her
saying zoo. Implying zoo equals dog. It was when she first came
on stream. It was awkward.
This guy is doing a lot of talking to himself. I I literally
look at this and I'm like, "Wait, did Lab delete her responses?
No.
Oh god, I'm showing his picture again. It's kick. Unfortunately,
you just got to stop being weird, bro. And then your picture
being out there won't be quite as bad, I think. I don't know.
Wait, Paragon is back. Yes, Carrier. If you were unaware, Paragon
was a covert spicy chatter. Okay, Chudlo Logic and Clement and
Purple Perry gaming fan. Purple Pepsi game. No, Purple Perry
gaming fan.
Undercover
was the whole time major Jay
You hate to see it. He got exposed again though for being weird.
He was messaging a 16-year-old. He added a 16-year-old as a friend.
Kind of kind of implied like, "Hey, I hope I'm interesting enough
for you."
Zanj says he's a dis Jtock hater. No, you're not, Zenj. You're
not. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me, dude. I don't even know.
I don't necessarily want to watch all read all of these, but
you can just get the sense of like I I just think I looking at
that the amount of he was DMing her. Not interested. Yeah, Lav
is like not interested and he just keeps spamming DMs at her,
right? Like Lav is doing
this. I probably would have gotten the hint. Like this is this
is very obvious the the hint she is giving here. Wait, hold on.
Yes, absolutely. But ironides just said Paragon's latest account
is quipoth quipoth
or something by the way. How do you know that iron sides? How
do you know that? How do we know? Some weird I can't spell. He
admitted it. Oh. Oh, well,
dude. I can't believe he's still around. That's That's actually
weird as that he would still be around at all, isn't it? It feels
like it's strange that he would Maybe not. No, actually, hold
on. No, it's not. It's like totally expected that he would still
stay like hang around. It's just uh it's weird to the rest of
us, I think. I was arguing with him. This guy sucks. I was arguing
with him and he was like, "You're using Destiny tactics." Which
I don't even know if I was, but even if I was,
it's based. It's cool. I I It's epic, okay, that I'm doing that.
Um, but it's like, dude, this guy was like gargling Destiny's
and balls when he like called into your stream to like defend
Paragon or whatever. It's like so bizarre. This guy's like, this
guy can't remember what he said like 5 minutes ago. It's so ridiculous.
Wait, sorry. Who are you talking about
Oh, wait. He called into my stream to defend Wait to defend Destiny.
Destiny called in with Paragon on your
And then like when I was over
Yeah. Yeah. No, he's he's like sucked up to Destiny in my opinion.
I got you. And then he accused me of using Destiny tactics and
it's like you're you're his top guy, dude. Okay. Huh?
I don't even know why he's that like he looks fine. Like he's
a fine looking guy. Why is he so insane?
Wait, I
getting one guy by Twitter right now and it's not good. Uh, he
is a fine looking guy. Obviously, if you're a janitor, that's
going to be a rough one in
Just I hate to get one guy by Twitter. I'll still follow coverage
of Tiny's court case, but Jtock has lost the ability to ever
criticize anyone for platforming than dating mentally ill women.
This was never a criticism. This was never a criticism. This
was never a criticism. This was never a criticism. This was never
a criticism. This was never a criticism. I don't know how many
times I have to say it. This was never a
You can't just redefine what the actual criticisms were. You
can't. I know that guy is like not a Destiny fan or something.
It's It's fine. It's not a criticism. Never been a criticism.
That would be a weird criticism. It was not. It was not at all.
You said that about Tom. I didn't, Mantis. But you are kind of
proof that um
like I don't criticize his relationship with you at all. Right.
You You actually are yourself the counter evidence I need. The
counter example I need. Thank you. I've never once criticized
him for dating you. All right. One sec. I'll be right back. No,
I I haven't ever once. It's awesome.
Look, Tom platformed and then dated a mentally ill woman and
I didn't have any heat for him at all. I was like, "Oh, that's
you're trying to relationship. That's based. That's beautiful."
Do you think it's okay?
Uh, it depends on what we're talking about, Cringleish.
But I do think it's okay to literally like start your stream
talking to somebody to get like convinced to stream by talking
to somebody who like invited you on their stream and then eventually
after you guys like run a stream together for like months to
have like a relationship with them. Yeah. People who think like
Cherry was my employee or like that was the relationship, that's
just crazy to me. But that's fine. Will be back. I disagree,
but I'll delete Oh, you don't have to delete the tweet. It's
okay. You can leave it there. You're ignoring me. Hold on. Because
they're mentally ill. No, it was because they're mentally ill
and they're in literal like actual anguish. They're in actual
anguish. Okay. At that exact moment, it was when he slid into
Kelly's DMs. You can go back. We went and watched that part of
the stream, right? They're not DMs. It was when uh Kelly was
crying and he like slid into the Discord channel, was talking
to her. Cherry wasn't paid anything. Uh, I can't. She was paid
at some point, yes, but I would have to explain further. I can't.
She was paid at some point, but I don't see her as like an employee.
Okay, fine. Uh, I Oh, man. How do I say
Ah, I just see like seem like a total s. I offered her 50/50.
I was like, "Hey, 50/50. We should be 50/50 on this. We should
be partners.
Turn it down.
it is what it is. Okay. It is what it
Mantis is losing it.
Uh anyway. Anyway,
it's fine. We keep we keep going. We go on with the stream. I
think we're done with the Star Bash thing. Although,
okay, I've been like Time for Kelly to get here.
I think I don't know if Kelly's coming actually now that I think
about it. I'm not totally sure.
Uh yeah, Cringle Kesh. The issue we have with Destiny is the
long-term like uh
Oh, I see. She may she may still be
Mantis, I don't know why you have like you can have hate for
me all you want. I don't know why you got to like drag other
people in. Just bizarre.
I don't know why you're so hateful.
I honestly like don't have that much of a problem with you. You're
fine.
I just You're very emotionally disregulated. I hope um I hope
things
Hold on.
What are we doing? Doing stuff in the background as well.
I'm glad I got your YouTube banned. Uh, you almost you did not
get my YouTube banned. I was going to say almost certainly. You
just straight up didn't get my YouTube banned.
I literally know why my YouTube got banned.
Like, I literally know. I've literally talked to people at YouTube,
like YouTube reps.
It is the exact thing. It was an automated check that got me.
Anyway, we continue. What are we doing here? Oh, I don't want
to start the Darius stuff until Kelly's here. She's uh she is
going to be here, actually. I'm not even joking. I'm not lying.
She is going to be here.
Dailies. I can't do dailies yet. Are we having a second trial
or a review of the old stuff? We are reviewing some of the old
stuff. Tenstone because he was revealed to be a
a Chudlo Logic Queen and Chatter. Okay. Chud was not a fan. I'm
just saying he uh he went to those communities and he was a guy
named Starbase or Star Bash. All right.
Uh Mantis, you can join the stream if you want.
You can totally join the stream.
I'm down with you joining.
You're fanning so much ignorance. I can literally go and pull
up the VOD.
Tom showed Mantis's on stream. No, that was a feminine trans
person. That's what it was. He didn't do that. Mantis, we love
having you chat. Okay,
I don't know if you know this, but chat messages actually feed
me money. They give me KCIP money. It's awesome. You being here,
you engaging everybody in the chat. You are helping me a lot.
So, I just very much appreciate you right now.
Is this the Mantis person that got rejected by Tom? No, I don't
think she got rejected. I think they dated.
We have excess stream time from yesterday. No, Cyberdrifter.
And
what? Cyberdrifter. Hey, hey, Dance.
They threw in like 30 subs right at the off the bat on the stream.
So,
I just feel like I feel like if I'm so wrong, if I'm so evil,
Mantis, shouldn't she be able to go through this without wishing
harm on anybody else? Shouldn't you? I feel like you should.
No, we're still here even though it's 2:20 a.m. What's up? That's
awesome. Uh maybe I should start streaming earlier just for Cyber
Drifter. Okay. Should start hitting that 6:30 start time. 6:30
Eastern. Maybe go a little back. I mean, you don't have to be
nice to me. I'm not asking you to be nice to me, Mantis.
Just asking you to be like slightly not a total piece of, but
it's fine if you want to be, dude. When I control Zed through
these things, that's crazy. Weird artifacting going on screen.
You're a Okay. I Hey, I'm just like I'm not even I'm not even
angry at you. I'm just like, "Hey, you probably just don't have
to do that." Yeah, it's a masculine trans person who's maybe
taking estrogen or something. They're just jacking off and making
a really gross face. It was just meant to be shocking.
Are these what the are these what the log said? This is what
Tom said. O
sent you a DM. You know this would be a great conversation.
Oh, you sent a DM to Mantis. Who this? Oh, it's Mau. He's
Up. I'm trying to get Mantis to come on
Which Mantis?
Uh, like Tom's girlfriend. Mantis.
I might have to leave for that. She really doesn't like me.
Um, I mean, do you think she dislikes you more than me? Are you
not aware of what I what she did on my stream?
I am not. What did she do on your She was like she was like eight
months sober and she came on my stream and relapsed publicly
for like an hour straight and started calling all the black people
in my chat like the hard part R. Are those Is that VOD up somewhere?
Yeah, it it is. You need to link that to me right now. Oh, I
would I would love nothing more. No. Yeah, it is. Um, I don't
know why
cuz I I had like little characters. I've fallen off JTO. I'm
going to be upfront with you. I had little characters that I
would bring on and she was one of them. Uh, and one day I brought
her on. She came in and and she was very obviously like drunk
or whatever. And um,
let me find this really quick. She She was um she's being very
bizarre. Very bizarre uh very bizarre experience.
Yeah. It's called Black Lives Matter. It was only 30 minutes.
It was not an hour. or I lied to you. I'm sorry.
Uh, this is when I very first started streaming, so the audio
and quality might be a little a little So,
No worries. I am psyched. I'm very psyched right now. Yeah, she
DM'd me after and she was like, "Sorry, I relapsed."
That's That's tough. And if she weren't in here like uh wishing
harm on other people, I would probably not even really entertain
this. but she just wants to come in here and like uh try to get
a reaction out of me. So, I feel like this is funny in base now.
I don't normally like making fun of people for this.
I actually had a whole thing where I talked to her about, hey,
I'm not going to make fun of your alcoholism. I feel bad for
doing that before. Okay. But now she's in here doing this. I
I honestly never took a swing back. think when she does all this,
I think it comes to a point where you um
where you're so bad of a person, like the things she defends
and advocates for and does all that. Like, yeah, it's probably
fine to make fun of her. Like, she's she's legitimately just
like outwardly genuinely racist. And like I I think racism can
be funny. I don't care that much. I'm not going to moral f over
it like to an extreme amount, but like if you're genuinely just
like calling black people gorillas and you're like, "Styler is
a monkey. I hate Stylus
scratching his armpits. That's like That's why like Tom's mod
team in Sassoprass originally, I think, had criticism for Mantis,
right? Was Tom would keep on banning her when she would be like
racist in their Discord and they're like, "Tom, we don't want
her in our community at all. Like she's just a total piece of
Tom would like on banan out." I'm pretty sure that's if I remember
correctly, that is what happened. And in classic Mantis fashion,
she comes to my chat and says, "Stylo is a monkey. Stylo is my
best friend." Okay. Do not make fun of Stylo in my chat. That's
crazy.
Yeah. I I think it comes to a point where you're just like genuinely
genuinely racist. So, it's like, yeah, I think we can make I
think we can poke a little fun at your like relapse, your like
pathetic wretch of a life or you're like a methhead and you're
dating a druggy, you know, pathetic loser who has never accomplished
anything and he had to suck Destiny's off so much, you know,
to get an aerodite raid to finally push past the 40 viewer mark.
Okay. I think it's fine to make fun of that girl who um you know
is obsessed with like loser wretch people and is genuinely just
like a racist uh piece of so I think it's
That's my take. My take. I don't speak for Jtock. My take. Listen,
I just feel like if she wants to come on stream, it's fine. But
we'll check it out. When did she actually join here? Cuz what
are you covering? Let's call. You can see on the Oh, you This
is really video, I think.
Uh, no it doesn't say. So, but um it's Insane that we're finding.
No, you can scrub and you'll see her picture show up like on
the Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But we'll we'll watch the context.
We'll see why she's uh getting at you here. General. Yeah. You
just posted You want me to show these on stream? Mantis, can
you say sorry to me? No. Why? What we had? Does it mean nothing
to you? I'm sorry. You're being a baby back.
I don't know what that means, Mantis. Why can't you be wholesome
and stuff? Fine. Sorry I called you the new nobody.
Wow. This is really groundbreaking stuff.
This is really groundbreaking stuff that we're finding out today.
This is really insane that we're finding I mean to explain briefly.
Uh she just wanted she wanted me to pull up these DMs on stream.
I don't know why. That's like the the context. Oh, is Mantis
banned from the Discord right now? That's crazy. Hold on. Uh
Mantis might be banned.
Give me a Holy Holy, dude. Oh my god. Big leaks. Massive leaks.
Massive leaks. Massive leaks. All because I won't call some dad.
By the way, dude. You know what? Let's call Mantis back. I'm
sure she has something incredibly intelligent to say. Let's see.
Maybe she has something funny to say. We'll see.
Here she comes. Mantis, why are you so upset?
Why are you so upset, buddy?
you very clearly are.
You keep messaging me. It's okay to It's It's okay. It's okay.
Constantly message me and say, "Why aren't you replying? Why
Why aren't you sorry? Why?" Like, "Why? Why? Why?" Mantis. Mantis.
Why? Mantis, it's okay to be upset sometimes. Why are you like
this, Mal? Why am I like this? Why do you keep reaching out to
me? It's weird. You're 21. Do you want to be groomed? Would you
like me to groom you? You want to be groomed now?
Why do you keep doing
Because I want to be groomed.
Are you okay? Never mind. Do you want to be
What is being censored out here?
I forgot. I I don't censor them anymore. I I was like super skitso
and overly censored in the past cuz I didn't want to get to,
but I don't really care You have the uncensored VOD. We are on
kick. If you had the uncensored VOD somewhere, you could like
send it to me. I could download it and I could No, I had to delete
all my old VODs because they were copywritten in order to get
monetized. I see. Yeah. Rough. Yeah, I had to do that at some
point. That's not the direction I was going with it. Would you
like me to put on a strap on not particularly? No. Why do you
keep me Hey, the one degenerate act that Maui is not going to
participate in. Let's go.
Let's go. Like you're
Why are you so mad, dude?
Why do you She's definitely calling you an F slur for sure with
the She said the
Keep messaging me like you're Okay, you got to stop with the
slurs. Okay, come on. Why do you keep messaging me like you're
All right. Like one more and you're gone. Okay.
Oh, yeah. You're a
I just don't want I don't want slurs on my stream, buddy. I'm
sorry.
You're very Listen, Mantis. Mantis. I think listen
mantis I think a more productive way to go about this conversation
would be to
what like
embrace thing
I can't believe why did Mantis rejoin this Mantis really rejoined
to come on stream because we're watching this
is not great
this is not great I I mean I don't I don't have much to say to
her this is your battle
uh I don't have anything to say to her either but honestly it's
just content
Mantis, you're on the stream. What is up, Mantis? How's it going?
Hola. I'm on my phone, so if I sound like that's why.
Okay. How's it going?
Pretty good. I'm definitely sober, so that's fun. How long? Watch
me relapsing. Always a good time.
You're saying some pretty unhinged things in my chat. I feel
like it's not even like a disproportionate response. They're
not that unhinged. I think you're not really used to push back.
You're just used to lying about other people though. It's not
that unhinged.
I mean, that's my problem with
all the time. You act like so confused why people wouldn't like
you. Do you have really have no idea why I wouldn't like you?
I know exactly why you don't like me. I just when I don't like
people, that like fades over time. But why do you act why do
you act like you don't understand? Then hold on. When I have
like to taunt with people, when I have like a conversation about,
hey, uh, I felt bad about making fun of your alcoholism and like
you were like, oh yeah, I was on Hinge, too. We had like a whole
call or a whole set of conversation, a whole set of DMs. Sorry.
No, we didn't.
I can assume we talked about this, did we not? No, dude. What
do you We talked about this on stream at some You realize you
realize it's not Hang on. You realize it's not just about like
you teasing me about my alcoholism, right? cuz I really don't.
Look, you know, everyone teases me about that. That's not We
talked about that, right? Am I I can't be I I feel like I'm insane.
We talked about Are you listening to anything I'm saying right
now? I'm saying about the alcoholism thing. I could have sworn
we talked about it and I was like, "Okay, I'll I'll like leave
this alone."
no, we didn't ever. What are you talking I'm positive we did,
but now I can't remember. So, I can't remember where it No. And
it's not And like I said, it's not actually that's not the reason
why. But do but you don't know the reason why, do you? Or you're
you're fainting ignorance because you're very manipulative. That's
You can't go for the reason why. No, I you you know what? You
should say the reason why. This is why Cherry wanted to kill
herself because you gaslight people.
Uh-huh. Okay. I literally just said, "Could you tell me the reason?"
Yeah. So, you lied about somebody I care about over and over
and over and over again, and it turns out that you were just
doing the exact same thing the What was the lie? What was the
lie?
Yes. Go ahead. Are you that dumb? Take a guess. That Tom's a
best. Well done. Oh my god. You have a brain. Okay. You understand
that? I took that back like publicly for you multiple times,
right? I literally said, "Tom, you should record this on stream."
I literally messaged him and said, "Hey, this isn't true." Yeah.
Multiple times. When you guys came in to fight about stuff, I
had made it very clear that I didn't think this was the case.
But then he did the whole thing with Kelly and then he had to
come and argue through See, there we are. You lie. See, this
is you lying. You say you take it back, but then you're what
you do is you talk out of both sides of your disgusting fat mouth.
That's what you do because you're a slimy. So, you talk out of
both sides of your mouth and then you act confused
people might have a problem with the weasly tactics and the the
message that you're actually putting out and then you just deny
that you're doing it. Like the problem is JTO is that it turns
out that every accusation you make about everyone else has just
come true. So you don't really have a leg to stand on anymore.
You are the test according to your
Wait, you understand that it wasn't really true until we found
the sulfur thing. Him staring at women on the right? We actually
did an investigation. We found it, right?
And you can't get rid of time. You can't get rid of how much
you tried. And you're still lying about it. You can't get rid
of time. We literally watched and counted to him like 30 seconds
just staring at this Asian women on stage. You realize that it's
just called being like a straight man. Are you like ashamed of
being a straight man? I mean, I can tell that you're ashamed
of like
I'm just hiding your
admit that you like totally switch it up. As I point out, what
I say is based in reality, based in things that happen. you start
going, "Oh, well, actually, this is just being a straight man."
I'm telling you the facts that led to people actually going,
"Oh, wait. Tom kind of is a best, isn't he?" But that's because
they are idiots and they listen to people like you who've redefined
what actually means and they actually lap that up because you're
piece of We just talk through what happened. Okay. So, so as
this conversation is exactly why I don't like you. You're a slimy
debate bro.
And then you then you treat other people who do debate stuff
like they're pieces of [__] You everything you do
is what you hate about other people. But you do it all the time.
And then you can't just cop it. You can't just like admit that
you are a slimy. You have to continue. And then you run around
and call other people out for all this that you just make up
about them. Everything you do is accusation.
So there's someone that I've made things up about aside from
Tom. So I don't want to I don't want to talk about Tom because
I just explained some of the facts and we don't want to go I
will assume that most of the that you talk about about other
people is exaggerated or hyper hyperbolic or like obviously some
like community like commentary community drama that you do where
you manipulate the situation to make people look way worse than
than they actually are depending on whose side you're on. You
did it to Destiny for months calling him a like you're
didn't call him a called him an
very clear about the delineation.
Oh,
you you put yourself in really bad positions, JTO, when you do
this.
This is why people don't like you. This is why everyone outside
of your little niche. Your Discord server is one of the most
deranged like degenerate places and then you treat everyone else
like they're degenerate. You understand that, right?
didn't you have while you were in the process of calling somebody
a falsely, didn't you have an NSFW channel and you were like
getting people in your Discord server were posting nudes of themselves
and you guys were all [__] Well, isn't that like
a thing in your Discord channel? And then you deleted it when
when it got me because you realized it looked hypocritical.
And so now you're an ex Destiny orbiter who has a mental illness,
right, Dr. K?
Am I right? Or you want to be her but you can't cuz she's probably
like
getting a rope or something and away from you. Maybe. Hopefully.
You need to chill going after this person. But yeah, had a relationship
with an ex. Oh, really? You don't like when people go after the
people you care about.
Uh when they're unrelated to the conversation. You want to come
in and talk about Tom. It's very it's very related because you've
put you've put yourself in a situation to be called out for dating
Cherry and everything to do with Cherry and what she puts out
publicly on Twitter because of the that you do to other people.
You've done this to yourself, JTO. Technically, if it's
regardless of how I treat other people. Yeah. Well, we can do
all of the above, which is what I just said. Thank you. All right.
So, do you understand now? So, you're not going to feain ignorance
and act like a manipulative freak. Do you understand why people
don't like you? Don't do you understand why I don't like you,
Dr. K?
I'm sorry. Go ahead. Go ahead. Say that
Yeah, I'm sure you didn't understand. I said, do you understand?
I wasn't listening to you. I was typing DMs. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
I You have always disliked me because of the Tom thing. Why are
you pretending it has to do with anything else? Well, it's it's
everything that followed after that as well because it just reaffirmed
how I know that you're a slimy, manipulative, abusive piece of
everything you do. the [__] Tom stuff. Because of
the Tom stuff
because of the Tom sexy stuff. Because of the like ridiculous
way you had to like ruin the pixie cage by going after Destiny
as hard as you did because of the way you go after everybody
on your How did I ruin the pixie cage? No, no, no. Focus in on
that. How did I ruin the pixie case? That's very interesting.
Nobody
optically optically optically you for pixie by calling Destiny
like the most deranged. You know that, right?
Because you came across like a idiot and you made Destiny look
good in like a situation where he could have just only looked
bad. Somehow JTO, you managed to make Destiny look You think
Destiny look
He looked better because of the way that you were framing things.
Unfortunately,
to who? You to a ton of people. They think you're deranged and
then that it takes the spotlight off the situation. You're calling
him an
You don't need to do that. I just want to get this I just want
to get this very I just want to get this very clear. You think
I made it look bad to people on Twitter to whatever people online
who actually give a about any of this crap? I don't think so.
I don't think there's any way I could do that cuz if they give
a
facts are pretty effective. Pretty effective statement. No.
Oh, that's why he's got more viewers now. Remember when you were
saying he's going to fall off? Like you're so dumb. I said the
best we could possibly hope for I think is like a 30% fall off
in viewers and more likely than not there'd be no fall off at
all. Yeah. Everything you've said about like Destiny Well, not
everything, but most of the [__] that you said about
Destiny has been has just made it I just I want to make it clear
that you just said something and then I said what I actually
said which was totally coherent with uh everything else that
that happened. Yeah, but see
viewers across both platforms right now. Okay. Well,
I don't think his YouTube viewership has picked back up either.
You predicted something correct and you think that's the point
of what I'm saying right now? Like, why do you do this? You hyperfixate
on like irrelevant Why do I Why do I point out that you're wrong
about what you said, right? Why do I point out that you're wrong
about what you said? Because it's irrelevant to my point. Why
don't you address my point? Why are you arguing this?
Your point is that I said a bunch of things that are untrue.
So then you say you said this and I'm like no I said this actually.
And you're like why are you arguing that you're correct on this,
right? You said I was I was in a bad situation because I lied
about people and then I said no this is what I actually said
when you made something I do you see like why that's the natural
progression of an argument. You ran this
and then you ran around getting everybody to try and call him
an and like leave this community and don't associate with him
around where you're basically you're basically
I just
Why are you denying?
I just saying it. You're in other people's streams. You're like
in your own stream. You're all I'm on Twitter saying it. I'm
on Twitter calling Destiny
Discord. on Twitter calling you. I don't want to dog pile. I
don't want to dog pile, but I do want to point out Mantis that
every time I asked you about the multiple lies that Thomas No,
I'm muting you. I'm not listening to Oh, okay.
Okay. I mean, well, you can talk to Just let me talk to Mantis.
I want to give the wrong impression.
Anyway, I my point in calling in is just to point out like I
I wish you would stop doing this like weird greasy thing where
you just like play play Edison on stream. Just [__]
be straight up. Stop talking like in a weird circus. You're like
a Dungeons and Dragons master rule master the way you talk. Like
why can't you just be normal? I don't play Among Us anymore.
Just be honest. Just be honest. You understand why I don't like
you. You just laugh. She just broke. I won. She just broke and
laughed. I won. I
Are you good?
Have you actually lost your mind?
she giggled. I won.
Sorry. What were you saying? Everything you do is cringe, dude.
Okay. Well, you get it now. So, good luck. You Dr. K juice.
That's uh good times. All right. Anyway, we can continue on with
this vod now. I don't know how she can like I don't know how
the she can climb any of that. She's I honestly was willing to
It's so funny that like
I'll just talk through people can get really mad about stuff.
I'll just talk through facts with them, right? I'll just say
like here are the facts for why I believe what I believe and
then like that happens.
Very simple. I I totally understand why so many people don't
want to come on the stream and talk, right? I just go this is
what actually happened and then they they totally trip over themselves.
I'm not even a good debater, by the way. I'm not. For anybody
who thinks I'm a good debater, I'm really really really not at
Uh, anyway,
sorry. I Dude, no, don't I don't need to make fun of Mantis's
appearance. No one thinks that of you. Yeah, I'm saying that
like I just have like I I'll have like three facts that like
give me an opinion. I'll just state them and then
and then you just get to win because you are correct. I don't
know. All right. All right. We continue on with this VOD.
Attack it from two. We're not going to make fun of Mantis.
God damn it. I say we're not and then Yeah. No, I'm not. Two
directions. One is Oh, that was the other thing is like I'm I'm
affecting Pixie's case. Where are any of my comments on Destiny
like cited in Pixie's case? Where is like the lawyer even being
informed of my commentary aside from by Destiny's team to say
like I'm a witness or not a witness? Right. Like none of the
none of the hyperbole has been cited at all. I don't know.
daughter and two is psychologically. Why are you like rejecting
that? Are you like emasculated?
Are you a
Why are you so mad? No, no. I'm asking a question. I asked you
a question. You seem very upset right now over something pretty
minuscule and it's a little confusing to me. Answer my question.
Mal or
why are you upset?
Sorry, I'm saying Stephen Jelly. She's saying, "Oh, because of
how hyperbolic you were, you up Pixie's case or up optically
or something, which I could even understand why Pixie would maybe
be upset about that or something. You just leave again. Is this
internet?" No, that's I'm hearing things. You just No, no, I
I I was going on another stream to argue like an evil. I'm back.
I'm back for good now. I'm back for Oh, based based. Oh, yeah.
Steen. So, anyway, that was her argument. I'm like, "Wait, where
is it cited in the court documents? Where are any of like the
things I said that might have been hyperbolic, which I think
is about as far as it went, right? But people just get to make
things up and then people want to take that narrative that's
made up and propagate it because they don't like me, which is
fine if you want to do that, right? I think the more you do that
in your career, the more you just take like narratives and try
to propagate them with the facts behind you, I think you you
end up grinding away at like the what do you call it? Like the
longevity of your career. But then again, I'm probably not the
person to consult on on making sure your career has a long lifespan.
So, realistically,
I'll just hit play on the video. Okay. Answer my question. I
have two. Why are you upset?
Answer my question,
Mantis. I don't think it's okay to be upset to this degree. Question,
Ralph, or did I not? I I think this is my stream and I think
I can, you know, control. Why are you evading? Why are you being
a Because I want to talk about why you're not running. It's kind
of weird that you're running. Aren't you meant to be a debater?
No, not really.
Not a big debate guy.
So, you just message me say, "Why don't Why won't you apologize
to me? Why won't you love me? Be my friend."
Because I want you to apologize and love me and be my friend.
I remember saying that, but why why the do you message me message
me without being your friend? It's weird
because dude, I think we can I think we can be a dynamic duo.
Kelly's arguing that if you make somebody if somebody's like
yelling at you and you make them like break and laugh in the
middle of them being angry that that's acting like that's a win
is weird. That's totally a win. That's like very obviously a
win. I don't know what we're talking about. I've already said
yes. I've already said Would you like to be friends or why won't
you answer my question? I would like to be groomed and be and
be friends. Three.
You good? Listen, I was playing to the audience at hand. Okay,
I'm sorry.
Answer my question. Be a good little submissive
and answer my question. Can you stop being so rude? You're being
very rude right now. No, I don't give a answer my question. I
think you would have a more productive conversation with me if
you were polite. I'm not interested in a productive
Then why why do you want to talk to me?
Why did you call me?
Okay, let's stop with the slurs. Okay,
we can keep going if you want. No, I Mantis slurs
So, this is hards now, I'm guessing. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you want me? Do you want to be my We don't say slurs. Okay.
Those are bad.
So then why'd you call me? Can you try to be a little more nice?
Why not?
We're not friends.
I think we can be friends.
Why did you message me all? Like it's weird. This entire thing
is because I said if you're going to talk to Ben, don't just
talk about the talk about like psychological fun Mr. Girl. Is
that why you're upset? And you took it like Yeah. And you forgot
I she she DM'd me out of nowhere and said that I should talk
to Ben and Grace Thorp and I was like I don't know if I want
to talk to
like I don't want to talk to these people. And then they're they're
like I was like if I do talk to them I'm probably just going
to meme it out. And they're like she got mad at that. She was
like no if you talk to them you need to talk about the psychological
aspect of it. And I was like no I don't care. I
I knew for a fact that when that when you said Ben and then she
was talking about that it had to be Ben Thorp. I just in my head
I was like, "Yeah, that's Ben Thorp." I just I connected those
two concepts like immediately.
I didn't say it though.
Did you talk to Ben and Grace Thorp?
No, I I I was told that if you do streams on them, they'll contact
you. So, I did like three in a row uh just seeing if they would
talk to me um and like reach out, but they didn't. And I was
like, I'm not going to put in the effort to like reach out to
them personally. So, I just kind of stopped talking about All right,
fair enough.
I have to like talk about the right only
Bye, [__] Wait, does she not rejoin? She does rejoin
eventually. No, she does. Yeah.
Okay. I think that marks the last time Mantis comes on stream,
I think. Oh, he's a s. He's He's not telling the truth. That
is not the last time she comes on stream. Damn, girl. Your voice
is hot as Dude, this is Rez. This is Rez. Dude,
Mantis is leaking all of my DMs. The DMs that I'm sending her
live. She's leaking them. She's leaking.
My stream will die without you. You got my viewers up. Please
come on so I get them. No, she's leaking my DMs in the in the
Queen and Jen chat that I'm sending her right now as I'm streaming.
This is so up. This is so up. This is so up. This is so up. This
is so
dude. She's so easy to bait. Holy sh Oh my god.
I literally have to I have to Do you get more Do you get more
DMs or I don't know what he's on. I might I don't know if that's
shown on screen. I I There's like three shots or something. She's
hopping on. Give me two seconds. I need to get more water, but
I'll be right back. Yeah. Yeah, you're good. If she's not watching,
I could probably get her a third time. What do I send her? Oh,
she called me. What's up, Mantis? What's up, buddy? All right.
I have you muted on stream because I don't want you to say any
more slurs. Okay. I don't I don't want slurs on the stream. I'm
sorry. Okay. What are you What are you What What substance are
you on right now, Dad?
Wow.
Oh, I wasn't I wasn't going to talk to Ben. You told You told
me that you could get me in contact. I never said yes or no.
Here's some advice. There she is. That's okay. Why are you being
such a
like you can't take it? Why Why are you being so rude? You're
being very rude.
You're leaking all the DMs that I'm I'm sending to you in confidence,
dude. What friends? What friends? Who? Who? Who? You're you.
Oh, you didn't realize you had your
up here, did did you? Uh, no. I I I muted her cuz I I didn't
know if this would get my stream taken down, but I still Yeah,
I I unmute her a little for cuz I was just like at this point
she's already said it like 10 times. It's It's going to get taken
down. It's going to get taken down. So, I see. You're the one
that made the claim.
Why can't you accept advice?
Because I don't really care about advice about talking to some
guy who his daughter. I don't I don't really care. So, like if
you're going to talk to someone, okay, so I have DMs between
you and Riyle about law.
You don't accept advice.
You and Riyle about lore. Lore to that guy. Just saying. You
don't accept advice.
I just don't really care.
You only accept advice from like who? Riyle kitten. When have
I asked for advice from Royal? Oh, it's Hey, Dance. This guy
just donated tonight. Nice. Why are you being such a What do
you mean? Is it cuz like I'm a female and you need to like assert
your dominance or something cuz you're 21 and you think like
I'm a misogynist. Oh, yay. Cool. I am I do I I do hate women.
Yeah. Oh, I'm I'm like I'm friends with Queen and uh I'm not
friends with Queen.
Why are you doing this? Are you Did I hurt your feelings? I can
Answer my question. I'm I'm I am sorry if I made you upset with
the way I was talking to you. Okay. Answer my question or off.
I don't
care.
Uh all I said was if you're going to talk to Ben, don't just
ask about the of his daughter. There's like so many cool Mr.
Girl routes you can go down.
That's
what are Mr. Girl routes? Is that like too much for your tiny
little She was She thought I was like a pseudo Mr. Girl because
I think I was I asked like dog warts or something and she thought
I was like a pseudo Mr. Girl guy.
I think you do that sometimes. I didn't think this is ever going
to last though you bringing people on cuz No, you like you go
I I try not to when people come on I try to form long-term relationships.
I think when I watch your stuff a little bit I was sometimes
like I feel like you're you're like
I don't know sometimes you like I mean I understand where you're
coming from but I will say I don't think there was ever going
to be a longlasting
sorry what was that
I feel like you had sick mantis on once and I was like dude these
people are these people look insane like you were making them
look crazy I do do it sometimes if you I don't know if you ever
saw a call I had with like a a guy who was talking about Christian
Zionist I did that I what You do. I did to that guy. Were you
like I really like I really liked sick. I I almost um got sick
and Lav on to read their leaked DMs together. Wait, you did get
sick and Lab on or you No, I almost I almost I almost I I asked
Lab if she would do it and she said yes. And then I I typed the
message out to Sick, but I was like, "This is probably really
mean. This probably really I don't I don't think I can do this."
So I I I I stopped because I I was worried that it was going
to be too evil.
Okay.
All right.
I think it could have been it could have been good. I don't know
who ends up winning there cuz I think that's rough for Sick,
isn't it? Isn't Sik like hitting on her pretty heavily?
Uh yeah. Yeah. I I I don't know. I understand what you're saying
about the um the like longevity of this. To be fair, I was never
like
like what the connection am I making here? Like Mantis and Tom
Foolery. like I don't like either of these people. I'm not a
fan of their content. I don't really care. Um
so I yeah, I understand where you're coming from, but at the
same time, it's just kind of like I don't I'm not going
I'm not going to befriend either of these freaks. I'm I'm fine
with, you know, doing doing a stream like with Tom goes like
hard on me, but he's like not the worst connection to have. He
knows a lot of people. I don't know if he gets them on all the
time, but he knows a lot of people. Uh I'm going to be honest
like him. I don't want to I don't want to sacrifice like I don't
want to be friends with someone that I I really don't like to
be honest. So I I understand what you're saying. I just don't
He's um he's not someone I want to be around, I think. Okay,
that's fair. That's probably fair to handle.
Yeah, I can tell cuz you flipped out. You're like, "Don't tell
me what to do. I'm going to like not be your friend. I'm going
to like freak out." And you
Mantis. Oh my god. Mantis is so like
your is like I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It's Mantis or your and you
haven't come out the closet.
No more. If you stop saying slurs. Okay. Okay. Well, you're muted.
You're you're muted on stream now. I can't have that. Okay. That's
funny. You can't say slurs anymore. I feel like that was an F
slur for sure, right? It was. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. 100%. Dude, how
did Mantis decide to come on and just like fail to make any point
when she when like the downside for her not coming on is we just
watch this VOD where she looks cool? Like the one time Mantis
has looked cool on a stream. That's crazy. I'm telling you, I'm
sorry. I'm apologizing. I've upset you clearly and I'm sorry
for that.
Yeah. Do you want to be friends? We can be friends. Mantis actually
want to be friends with me. You just you you Oh, you don't like
me? How long until he brings her back on?
Hate me. Oh, I the Pikachu costume. I I do live in America. Well,
there's no use to me because I hate you. You hate Why do you
hate me? I think you're of no use to me. I want to be by a giant.
Oh, I see. Well,
yeah, I can. Why Tom keeps that head shaved so close? Okay. I
I do live in Well, there's some road
blocks we'd have to cross before we even got there, right? I
do live in America. You live in New Zealand, so I think there's
a lot more to worry about before the size. I wouldn't even bother.
I wouldn't even bother chasing you because you're tiny. Tom Fuller
is huge, by the way. Massive. I would chase that. You already
have. I think I would. I haven't quite yet, but I I think you
have. Wait, what the
feeding time for Princess again. I really just love watching
her get bigger from my blood.
This person has a leech that they put on their arm intentionally
to let it suck their blood. You haven't seen this picture before?
I've never seen this. I don't know what this is. Is this old?
Uh, well, I've seen it before. I don't know how long it's necessarily
been around, but yeah, it's a very funny
I will. Do you don't think you've chased his? His is 100% bigger
than yours.
You're in a Pikachu costume. You look like a cat. You're a idiot
and you don't know what to say half the stream. You messaged
me every day saying, "Can I go host? I'm bored. I don't know
what to do." Blah, blah, blah. I don't think I do that. Yeah,
you do. I No, I I think I've asked you to similar to Queenman.
Quan messaged me when I was friends with him. I'm bored. I'm
bored. I'm bored. Do something like, "Let's make content." Messaged
you saying he was bored? I don't think that's true. To clarify,
that sounds like Queman. Okay, that sounds like Que. I think
Quan probably did that. Queen was probably spamming Mantis's
DMs.
I think so. I think that I could see that. Okay, that guy is
way more that guy is just like uh very like genuine and very
emotional person in DMs. All right. Every time
[__] day, dude. Every day.
He was so like we would hang out all the time. There was nothing
[__] happening. It would be me going and doing things.
Quinnman is a coward.
Quinnman's a coward. I just want to make it clear to you guys.
Quan's 27 or 26, one of the two.
Good question. Ask him. You're the one that made a claim,
He says, "I'm bored all the time. He has nothing going. He's
always looking for something to do because all he does, he doesn't
make content. He reviews
Quuman will never hit Twink because he doesn't go outside for
one thing. He never sees the sun and he eats like 300 calories
a day. All right.
He'll never experience Twink. He will look like that for the
rest of his life.
He's a chain smoker. Oh, I forgot about that one. He is a chain
smoker a little bit. Not a chain smoker, but he does need to
walk away and smoke every once in a while. So, that's what you
do. You're an idiot. You're a commentary community nobody. You
review content. You don't make
that's true. I am sorry for hurting your feelings. No, you're
not. Don't I feel bad that I've made you upset. No, you don't.
Yes, I do. I want to listen. I listen. Hold on. I appreciate
it. I appreciate the apology. Unfortunately, you're
I would like it's huge. Okay, that's okay. I I believe you. I
believe you. I want to be your friend. And as a gesture of good
faith, I'm going to apologize for making you upset because I
did not want to do that. That's not what friends do. Okay. Why
do you want to hang out after this?
You want to hang out after stream? Moral, I'm asking you a genuine
question. After this, do you want to hang out? We can hang out
after stream if you would like. What? Do you want to hang out
on stream? If you don't say slurs, why are you being so weird?
Like, why do you like me? I think you're a very interesting character.
Why do you like her? Why do you like her? Say right now, Mal.
Uh, no. I'm just I'm laughing at I I say you can, we can hang
out on stream if you don't say slurs. And then her reply is,
"Why are you being so weird?" That is odd. I, you know, cuz I
know Ralph was probably saying slurs in DMs a lot. He was like,
"Hey, you look kind of ethnic. Could you write this on your chest
for me?" And she And now she's like, "Why are you being so different
when we're on stream?" Right.
Not to Mandis. Okay. She's too pale. Why are you so Why are you
so gay? I'm I'm I can't help it. I'm sorry. So, okay, tell your
audience that you love me and you want to hang out with me even
though I'm annoying and you want to ban me from chat. And then
tell me that Syo is a chimp. Please. Why would I tell you that
Silo is a
Just do it for funies. But I like Styo. I would never call him
a chimp. Just say it. He won't care. He's a He'll get over it.
Sty told me in DMs that if I call him any like I'll never speak
to you again. I have to call Stylo a chimp or else he'll never
talk to me again.
Say you okay at the very least say Stylo chimps out. Why Why
do you dislike Stylo so much? He's a chimp. Just say he's chimps
out and then I will love you forever. But I But I feel like that
would be really mean. I don't think you can use me for content.
You can abuse me. You can like I can abuse you. You can abuse
me. If you say Stylo is a How would I go about abusing you? What
does that even mean? It means Stylo is a very cool guy. Very
cool, smart, funny guy. though, right? Let's Can we I don't know
why she would say this. This is crazy. I just want to debate
JTO. I don't know what you want to debate me on. Depending on
what it is, possibly not open for We're not commenting on any
of the other stuff
You want to come call me a hypocrite or something though? I'm
down. Good with Means say this one sentence and then say whatever
you want. Well, I I don't want to be mean. I don't want to be
mean on the internet.
Well, you're a loser then. Why?
Because I think there's more value to be had with being nice.
Which is why again I listen Amanda I want to be friends and I'm
sorry for making you or I'll never pick you again. I I feel like
if you're willing to do ultimatum like that you won't you aren't
really going to be my friend. I feel like you're going to try
to win things over me. True true story. Yep. True. Why are you
being so rude? Because I don't give a about you unless you say
this one thing. Do we know why she hates Stylo so much? Uh yeah.
Skin toned obviously.
I What? What? What's going If I had to guess, I'm assuming Stylo
just like shot on her a bunch and spicy or something and she
like Yeah, Styl probably. Yeah. You don't care about me unless
I'm racist to a black man who just played Pokemon with me for
like an hour.
I feel like he's he's done more positive in my life than you
have. He's played Pokemon with me and all you've done is say
slurs on my live stream. Wait, is that it?
Well, we haven't really spoken much. We just play Pokemon once.
Yeah. What did I do for you? Well, I I don't really remember.
My memory is pretty. Could you tell me what you think you've
done for me? We had a stream on Mr. Go. So what the you're saying?
Mantis is racist. Well, she said the hard R multiple times. And
not only that, she's the hard R multiple times. She I don't know
if saying the hard R is racist, but I think if you're calling
a black man the hard R, that's probably Yeah. Keeps calling Stylo
a monkey.
Over and over again.
Uh, some dude's here to debate apparently. He's server muted,
so that's probably not great. Why is this guy server muted?
Do I have any mutuals with this guy? No. Hold on. Hold on. Let
me do a quick investigation. What does this guy want to talk
about? I don't know. Hold on. We'll pull him in. We'll see what
he has to say.
Expecting this guy to possibly be a troll because he's got the
uh the whole muted mic thing. We'll see.
Oh, wait. Hold on. I'm on I'm on my laptop. I need to switch
to the good mic computer otherwise I'm going to sound like Give
me a moment. Okay. Rejoin the waiting room when you're ready.
He thinks this server is a doxing server. Okay.
Uh that one I mean I guess we just have to start from like oh
what evidence do you have? Okay. And you keep messaging me about
wanting to be my friend. It's kind of weird. I think there are
issues like where people have you know they know things about
each other and they have put information. But that's that's not
like um I think when people say it's a doxing server, I would
have to delineate and say like do you mean it's a server that
like coordinates to try to dox people who are like critical of
it or something or critical of me or something like that? That
would probably be more what it is because I think there have
been like petty dramas where people have been like, "Well, I
know your name's this, right?"
It's like, okay, that's not really a doxing server. That's like
people getting overinvested in Discord and then like freaking
out in each other. It's like very different.
Yeah. Well, I think we could be friends. I think we should. Thanks
for being here. Yeah. So, say the thing. I am not going to sacrifice
one Bye. Have a great life. Bye. I don't play negotiations with
Mantis, can you be nice?
You want to hang out?
You want to hang out after stream?
Okay. This North guy is here now. This guy came on. He wants
to debate. North, what's up? What do you want to talk What's
going on? All right, I can call you egistical, right? Yeah. What
do you want to talk about? Uh, honestly, I have no clue. I just
wanted to say hi. Um,
I don't I don't know that much about you. Um, sorry. It's a It's
a criticism. It's a criticism if you have criticisms.
Oh, I have to have like specific criticisms with you. I just
usually Yeah. like people to have
So, what would you say your political ideology is? Okay. We're
not We're not debating politics right now. There's like a lot
of dramas going on. Oh, you don't Oh, so Oh, so you only want
to debate drama. Okay. Um,
well, if you want drama, trust me, it's okay. But, uh, listen,
you got to you just know what you want to talk about when you
join, dude. You Well, dude, well, I'm just wanting to chat. I'm
kind of bored. Um, yeah, see, that's exactly what I'm avoiding.
So, I'm I'm
like specific Yeah. Yeah. If you have like specific criticisms,
I'm not taking like open calls right now about any topic. I just
most a lot of people have been wanting to hop on a debate. No
worries. Thanks for coming on. Okay. Talk to you later. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Byebye.
Yeah. Just not just not like, "Hey, what's up? I'm like kind
of bored right now. I thought I'd hop on." No, stop. You got
to stop, bro. What? I'm sorry for making you up. You really You
really can't say that. Style at times. Chimps out. I don't No,
because that's that's a racist joke. What's so funny? That's
a good soundboard.
That's a really good soundboard. You want after stream?
Okay. I'm sorry for making you You really You really can't say
that. Stylo at times checks out. I don't know because that's
You really can't say that Stylo at
I can't finish that sentence cuz I wasn't going to say what she
said. That's a racist joke and I don't do
Why not? What a loser. Because that's a joke made through hate.
Racist jokes are funny. Why do you not They're not funny. They
are. You're like the opposite. Racism is nothing to joke about.
And like can I Okay, I'm not looking at your chat. I'm going
to look at your chat. Are they saying racism is not based? Please.
My chat is hold on. This is the uh the seven donation that went
through my stream. I have no idea what this was about or sorry
went through to Chud's stream when he's covering the the stuff.
This is the seven donation.
this is about me. Oh, this is about me.
Which I'm just like I don't I don't know what uh I literally
don't know what this means. I if somebody knows what this means
who not who's not seven, I don't need to talk to them on stream.
I just don't know what this would mean. I think I have my opinions
on seven. I'm going to keep my mouth I'm gonna I'm gonna, you
know, I'm gonna
quiet down a bit.
No. Well, oh, you think it's about Tom? I don't think it's about
Tom.
I saw that and I assumed Tom, but you
No, I don't know if it's about Tom.
I assumed it was about me and I was like, "Oh, that's weird."
But I don't need to talk to her on stream. I don't want to like
fight with her or anything. I just would be curious what what
it's about. Yeah. Like I know she left the server. She was literally
a mod.
So, I don't know.
No, I won't ask. I won't ask that. I just Yeah, I don't know
what this uh I don't know what this is about. I would just love
to know what it was about. Like what happened?
So for unrelated reasons. Yeah, that's what I thought. It had
nothing to do with you. That's what I thought. I But then this
donut came through. So I just I actually don't know. But I don't
want to fight about it or anything. Just if somebody um
if somebody knows if it's like a problem with me, I would want
to know. Anyway.
very my chat is very PC. They wouldn't say stuff like that. I
You're actually dropping the ball. Why
dropping what ball? She's so based. Bottoms up, mantis. Thank
you. Well, that's a message by Drama. He's a
Racism is okay when funny. I'm not funny. Blah blah blah. Like,
you guys are so dumb. Whenever there's actual racism, you guys
don't laugh. It's only cuz I'm a female. I get it. I get it.
I get it, baby. I get it, baby. I get it. You don't have to call
me baby. That's okay. You don't have to call me that one. Okay.
It's okay, baby boy. What do you You don't have to call me that.
I think we can manage without it. Okay. Okay. Well, we don't
have a relationship after this. Goodbye. Why? I plan on being
friends with you. I'm not. Bye.
Antis keeps beating you. It's really [__] up. She
doesn't rejoin either. She's like I do think after this she I
I believe after this she blocked me and then did not unblock
me. I believe I love morale. I love moral. Uhoh.
Uhoh. I believe Mantis credits Stylo with the reason she was
chased out of Spicy, which is the
Why do you let them hate you out? If you just stand up to unbridled
hatred for like a couple months, they hate you like 4% less at
the end of it. Okay,
it's fine. It's I don't think I'm going to watch anymore, but
No, I mean, yeah, that's that's the that's the end. That's that's
Yeah, that's it. Unhinged. Uh, it is a bit unhinged, but I just
don't
I'm not worried about it
Okay, what else do we have here? Oh, there's the Amar thing.
Apparently, Nick and Amaran have gotten a fight at the beginning
of their Taiwan trip. Why are they going to Taiwan? Nick went
live while they were fighting. Oddly enough, I have no idea why.
I'm definitely not leaving here before I get started.
No [__] I just think maybe it could be interesting.
Maybe it's interesting. Maybe it could be good stuff. This is
starting again. Apparently
when I have a constructive I literally briefly and then shut
up, dude.
Oh, I skipped way too far forward. Thought you said you already
live. Shut up, dude. Can you not
You don't want to help, but you're going to sit here and you
just told me earlier you were alive and I briefly and then it
crashed instantly. Yes, that's what I just said. Okay, that I
didn't hear the crashed I've been saying that. Well, I thought
you meant team crashing. No, you meant OBS crashed. I I I literally
said OBS.
What is the gist of how all the drama lost its momentum and she
just folded? Oh, Nacha Mama, thank you for the raid. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Welcome, Nacho Mama viewers. We're checking
out um Amaranth fighting with her husband, Nick Wick Lee, uh
in
I just went back in the VOD. Whoops. Yeah, we're checking this
out right now. Just a little drama. We love drama here with Drama
Frogs. Welcome all the Nacho Mama viewers. Thank you very much
for the raid. Nacho Mama. Well, I thought you meant team viewer
crashing. No, you meant OBS crashed. I I literally said OBS.
I just literally said OBS keeps crashing. Okay, I did not hear
that. I No, I just don't like it when like when I have a constructive
question that you could answer, you choose not to. Don't look
at it right now. That's fine. But don't nitpick the answer that
you can't help with either.
Like you know what I'm saying is please don't tell me to shut
up. I'm going to say what I want say. Nick, there's no reason
for that. I have nothing but helpful to you today. So it seems
like Nick's OBS crashed
my very last. Wait, Nacho Mama, are you Wait, Nacho Mama, are
you done? You don't mean streaming, do you? I didn't know you
were done streaming. A kick will miss you if that's the case.
I hope
Who's not? Everything's cool outside. You're done. Oh, that's
too bad. Well, I hope you had a good last stream. Hope you had
a fun last stream and
good luck with whatever you're going to next. Yeah, I get it.
It'd be like that sometimes. All right.
Oh, we'll we'll miss you, Nacha Mama.
Yeah. Thanks for thanks for all the memories. Thanks for coming
on stream a bunch and interacting with the community. We always
look for you when we're looking to raid after the stream. We'll
miss you. Have a good one, Nacha Mama. We'll see you. We'll see
you later. Uh hopefully you can come back around. Hope you'll
come and uh check out stream
Okay. All right. I hope uh I hope everything's all right outside
of streaming and yeah, everybody miss you.
07's in the chat for Nacha Mama. All right. We uh should probably
continue on. I didn't know that. That's uh until comes first.
So true. Yeah. I mean, who knows? Maybe you take a break for
a while and you might come back at it different angle.
Who knows? Get get happy
and we'll be we'll be happy to have you back, too. All right.
We'll see you, Nacha. Mama.
You're having very nice. Don't talk to me like that on here.
Don't you talk to me like that. You're You can tell me to mute
it if you want to, but don't tell me. You can tell. You cannot
say shut up to me when I'm just asking a question. Dude, if you're
asking You told me it crashed. So, are you live or are you not?
Cuz you told me it and then it just got live again. Yes. Then
what do you mean you're you can't leave until you get started.
It's already started. I don't know what the that means. You just
said you can't leave. Yeah, guys. I know. Started. That's a weird
That is a weird thing to say. Okay. No, it crashed, guys. It
crashed. It crashed. It crashed. It
Sorry, not guys. Uh Kate, it crashed. Okay. And then you're actually
just live the whole time while you're fighting. And now it's
like it's already started. So what are you talking about? The
moment after I said that it actually went without crashing. Wait.
Well then stop gaining
me. No. No. It's it's you. You asked. I literally do not. You
said are you live or you helpful to you this are you or are you
not? And I said you don't need to tell me to shut up Dude.
No. If you're going to do this on stream, I'll do this on stream.
You did this on stream. Did it on. I was trying to get live and
I told you that and then you decided to try and call me You Yeah,
because you told me to tell you when I don't like things that
you do, you communicate on stream. No, I don't. You can just
say I'm sorry. No, I'm not going to. That's stupid. No. Uh, updated
percentage chance this whole arc is fake. Um, I think they fight
legitimately and I think they know putting those fights on stream
will be content,
but um, but like I don't think it was fake to begin with. I think
it was real fights and then I think they continued on with those
fights knowing that they weren't really that sincere. They just
continued on with them and it's like uh now it's starting to
feel a little weird. If you're going to put on a front I'm not
putting on a front. I don't even know his lying cuz you told
me it and then why the [__] would you ask the Cuz
I'm confused. I was going to ask like what are you talking about?
Cuz you want me to help you. But when I told you that we're not
going to leave until it gets live trying to get us to leave.
But when I told you the answer, you decided to dance or something.
Sorry. No, I'm not going to. I'm not getting one of those. Well,
I'm probably getting a [__]
Well, I'm sorry. I brought you here Me, too. That's weird, but
okay. Okay, it's not too late. We're still in the city where
the airport is. No, the only here is you. Okay. I'm not the best
cry and break [__] day longer.
Why are you so deadly?
What is wrong with you? People next door, bro. Oreo spoke on
you. Yeah, I know. Uh I'm I'm probably done covering that stuff.
If it's something that didn't get answered on the stream from
before, then maybe. But yeah, realistically,
I'm not that worried about it. Uh I think
I think there's just a lot of um
oh, how could I put it? With the next up, I'm guessing it'll
be something of the form of like I didn't really watch the criticism.
I don't really know what the criticism was, but I can't take
it seriously because of this reveal, right? I don't know what's
I don't know like the specifics. I don't know any of it, but
I know I can't take it seriously. And the issue there would be
if it's like justified criticism, you're probably giving somebody
the ability to sneak under it. Um, if he just said he doesn't
trust me or my opinions, that's fine. I feel like he probably
should stop short of saying like, "I don't trust the the criticism,
right?" Yeah. So, he just like Yeah. It won't be like actual
engagement. It'll just be like, "Oh, vibes wise, I don't trust."
And it's like, "Well, vibes wise, he already thought I was a
like he already he already wouldn't engage with me. He already
didn't like me. He was already
nothing's changed, right? He's just saying it out loud. I guess
nothing I don't even this morning. I'm trying to help you out
your stream." You're right. Yesterday, all you have to do is
not stop and shut up and say I'm sorry. No, sometimes you need
to shut the
Jeez. Jesus Christ.
What an [__] I don't believe you. It's supposed to
be live. I can't when you want to stream. Yeah. Go yourself.
I will. You know. Good. Go home.
Dude, I don't I don't understand. How is it worth it for like
a 75 viewer stream I or 100 viewer stream. I don't even hate
Nick, but like the stream's not that good that like it worth
having these fights live.
It's really not. I don't I don't get it
wrong with you.
I told you that I might be live and then it keeps crashing and
you just say I'm sorry.
all these hate you asked me to mute it,
You keep telling me that you died and then it crashed. I'm going
to give you one last chance to lower your voice before I go over
the
You're so confusing.
There the Oh man, it's all coming back to me. There's like the
subtle like you need to stop or I'm going to be I'm going to
be so real right now. You need to stop what you're doing or I'm
going to be so I'm going to get I'm going to do the thing. I'm
going to do the thing you don't want me to do. It's amazing.
[__] See, there it cracked again. I have no control
over this. It just keeps crashing again and again and again and
But what I'm telling you when I say I'm live, it is true. And
then it crashes and then I even tell you every time it crashes.
So I don't know where the confusion lies. I'm literally saying
when you say a crash, I don't know if you're about OBS or Team
Viewer. I'm coming on. If you don't know, you got to ask. And
I did say I did ask and then you said shut up. I'm like, I'm
just asking a question.
I literally You literally forgot what I Team Viewer has not crashed
yet. It's always been OBS,
period. And I've never cuz you kept asking for the passwords.
I sound like Team Viewer's crashing.
Dad's calling me. Are we going or Yes, we're going. Team Viewer
is like uh like remote um
Oh, it's just like remote control software. Remote control. There's
a name. Remote access software or whatever, right?
Like I think it's just a way of like setting up a way to like
get into a PC and do stuff. RDS. Yeah.
Hold on. What is RDS? Sorry, let me Google it.
Uh remote desktop services? Yes. I'm not so [__]
sure. You got to [__] palm the [__] down.
How do you call? I've already told you this before.
Well, then I'm not going then. You go. No, it's my family. You
get you you stay the [__] back. I'm staying here.
Oh, they're going to Nick's families apparently.
Good fights when you're about to go do some family event.
No, you can stop being a douchebag. What the is wrong with you?
[__] yourself. I have to find somewhere to ruin everything
we do. yourself. I didn't do anything to you today. I've done
nothing to you. No. Okay. Do Do you actually want an answer or
do you just want to [__]
try to help you this morning while trying to do my own thing?
All I did yesterday was carry your bags around. Why you shopped
into everything? What the I was like, what did you guys do? I
Okay, I'm doing
Listen to me. Listen to me. That's something you like doing?
Why Why are you throwing random things around the I don't need
it right now. Okay. Okay. I'm going to ask you one more time.
Why are you throwing random things around the room? Yeah, that's
a I'm flustered. I'm sorry. Yeah, exactly. I can't call you.
I don't give a [__] I Oh, really? We're going to
do that again? We're going to
Say it with your full chest, you piece of [__]
Call me a [__]
Oh, he just Yeah, he just dropped a c word, didn't he? I heard
it. Oh, really? We're going to do that again? We're going to
mumble.
Say it with your full chest, you piece of [__]
bro. This fight was like nowhere and now it's like at full volume
like screaming
calling me. If you're going to mumble [__] wrong
with you,
you're going to mumble that first. What are you doing?
Maybe don't say, "Oh, you're crazy. I don't like the mumbling.
Stop doing this.
I asked you not to." I asked you not to. What's wrong with you?
Let me ask you not to [__] keep doing the [__]
mumbling thing.
There's no reason to. If you want to say it, say it. Don't go
crazy. What is that supposed to do? What is that supposed to
do?
Just stop. You can either resolve this now or never your call.
Why are you being so dramatic? No, it's not dramatic. It's very
simple. You go, you should not have said that. Pure Indian. Um,
so so that's correct. But you should have corrected me because
they have no context for that. I I didn't know you were lying.
You kept telling me it crashed. Crap. I don't know what's happening.
I said I did not know you were alive. First of all, first of
all, dude, the least you can do is just say
No, not if you're going to jump down my throat like that. I didn't
do down your throat. I just said, can you not shut up?
All I said you don't like it when I'm rude to you when I stick.
Okay. Are you done talking or can I
It's kind of hard to feel bad for her when she does sound incredibly
annoying.
Bro, I
it's just like rough to listen to right now. This isn't even
like their other fights where Nick was just like cuz Amaranth
usually was pretty calm like a lot of the time. I don't know
why she's uh she's like obviously way more upset like very early
in this fight. I'm guessing because of the like, oh, I was actually
live while we were yelling at each other right there. I'm guessing
that's thrown her off quite a bit. Sorry, I'm not getting into
the annoying thing. You're just a misogynist, bro. I don't know
why you're like that. Huh? Why you like that? I don't Why are
they still together? Is it just because they're making money
off of this? Why the are they still Yeah. Yeah, obviously. Oh,
okay. W Yeah, they're Are you done walking? Well, hold on. I
don't even think they're making money. Isn't Amaranth going back
to Twitch? I thought Amaranth is like not even staying like exclusively
on kick. Yeah, I know. Space Ghost. I know you used the soundboard
on the way out. Thank you. I know. I don't think so. you guys.
I think what we never like look at here is like Amaran's just
this is like how her life's gone. I don't think she she's just
like consistently just going to slide back into this pattern
unless something like gets bad, stays bad, and she like gets
separation. I think I think she's going to keep falling back
into this pattern, which sucks.
I wish that weren't the case, but that's kind of why I moved
on because I was like, "Oh, it's either it's either scripted
or like it's like too sad." But I don't know. Somebody somebody
linked this today and I was like, "Oh, I'll check it out. I'll
check it out." Oh, Assad is bad. Assad is bad. Assad is bad.
There you go, guys. There you go. Are you going to actually listen
instead of interrupt me every time?
I told you it's a clear example of you not listening because
I told you I'm live by the way. And then I go, "Oh, OBS cracked."
I literally said the word OBS, but that's fine. Let's say you
didn't hear that. And then I said, "Okay, you know, like um you
know," and you go, "I thought a little bit later you came back
to competition." He said, "Oh, I thought you said crash." I go,
"Well, it did at that time, but now back up." I literally said
that and then right after that you turn around and you said,
"Well, can I get an apology for like You don't I can't I don't
know if I can listen to this for much longer. I'll go another
like 5 minutes. I hope it just Don't do that. I hope it just
switches." No, you said it wasn't live and it crashed. It crashed.
The crash.
So, what I heard at the beginning of this was it crashed, right?
That's like what I heard at the very beginning of I'm definitely
not leaving here before I get this started.
I'm definitely not leaving here before I get this started. Implying
it's not started now. There's no Keep listening. Keep listening.
Keep listening. Thought you said you already live. Shut up, dude.
Can you not?
But you said you're already live. Shut up, dude. You don't want
to help, but you're going to sit here. You just told me earlier
you were live and now briefly and then it crashed instantly.
Yes, that's what I just said. Okay, that I didn't hear the crashed
I've been saying that. Well, I thought you meant team Ver crashing.
No, you meant OBS crashed. I I literally said OBS just keeps
I told you to shut up. I just Okay, just OBS just keeps crashing.
I do not believe that was ever um that wasn't on the screen.
Literally said OBS keeps crashing. Okay, I did not hear that.
I No, I just don't like it when when I have a constru
not to
look at it right now. That's fine. Reox, you missed Mantis on
the stream. Mantis called it. the random [__] that
you can't help with either.
Like you know what I'm saying. Please don't tell me to shut up.
I'm going to say what I want. Say, Nick, there's no reason for
that. Okay. I get the impression, unless I miss something here.
I'm getting the impression that the stream is currently not live,
right? Am I the only one to live right now? I'm live right now.
You're being very nice to me. Don't talk to me like that on here.
Okay, now he's saying talk to me like that. You're live. You
can tell me to mute it if you want to, but don't tell me. You
can tell. You cannot say Okay. All right. Got it. Got it. Said
you will not leave till you get it back up. The last thing you
said was I will not leave till I get it back up. Which means
that's not true. After what? That's to me I think Amaran's like
on point here. I think she's correct. Unless I unless I missed
something cuz it seems like Yeah. He said it's I'm not leaving
till this is up. It's been crashing repeatedly. Was this the
essence of what he said? Lasting after what?
Before I asked you, can you not tell me to shut up? Okay, that's
not true. That's not true. I had said that. You're like you're
like operating on like about a minute behind on that conversation.
Wait, I don't When you say it crashed, I don't know what it is.
Well, then you know what? Instead of I tried to ask. That's what
I did. I literally asked until you shop. No, no, no, no. You
didn't even I thought I thought you said it crashed because I'm
not leaving. I thought I was going to get You said I'm not leaving
till I thought I was going to get the talk. Are you just going
to keep interrupting
I said it cracked. If you assumed OBS, you didn't ask that. You
literally said like I won't leave till I get up between it's
not live currently. And so then I'm like okay. And then I reconnected
OBS after again. No, you're not there anymore. What are you doing?
You're saying a crap.
I So when he said these things, he was literally live.
I don't even know. Like this feels I don't even know if it's
I don't even know if it's scripted. Like it feels like he was
just intentionally trying to start a fight or something. You're
complaining about stuff. actually very wrong. I
uh Kelly's back now and I think she might be feeling ill, so
we could just go over the Darius stuff. Anyway,
read my What did you say? He said finally right as she interrupted
him. So, it seems like he got it going, but the fight started.
Sure, he said finally. That's not actually No, wait. You know,
things go wrong. You don't recorrect it when now it's good Uh,
no. I I tried to, but you were asking questions because you kept
asking me. You kept me trying to ask me and and you kept telling
me I'm just trying to help you. No, you weren't. You were trying
to not help me. You said I can't help you right at that time.
And then I asked what is I thought you said it crashed. Okay,
that's not that's not a
I literally Okay. Okay. What do you think you said that in response
to Oh my god, this is so dumb. Just packed.
Oh, I just missed what that was. Yo, Top Bronson, thank you for
the 16 months. Let's go. Done packing. I've been done packing.
Well, there's still tech stuff out. You're I don't know. I laptop.
That's it, right? That's it. You need to pack your stuff better.
It's just literally Okay, that backpack was out. You put it in
Okay, because you're not doing it because I was
yourself, dude. I was If you can't notice, do you know what that
pulled up to? What do you think I was doing with the laptop?
Don't you see that? Oh, boy.
We're ready to go. Oh, you're my only
you the blow up. I thought someone trying to get attention. I
think we go from here to the Darius stuff, right? I think we
go over there. We check that out
cuz I get these two are just yelling at each other and I've kind
of kind of lost the taste for it to be honest with you.
Kind of just lost the taste. It's just not hitting the same.
If she started to talk to him how he is talking to her, he would
lose his mind. Yeah, obviously
we've analyzed it to death.
Now, I don't think I've covered this on stream. I watched a little
bit of this when it was happening, but uh Darius ended up getting
charged and spending a night in jail apparently a couple days
ago. Was this two, three days ago now? I think it's like three
days ago now, but
he ended up spending the night in jail.
Let's see here. Uh there's So, there's a couple players here.
There's Zeus, who is Zakiro. This is the guy who used to be in
the Discord in discord.gg/jsdlk.
All right. People in the discord channels tried to convince this
guy to go to college. I believe he said that he's like retired
from military disability and doesn't have to work
He was in jail for two nights. Damn.
So that's the guy who was living with Darius. Apparently he was
just like a viewer. I don't know. He's like 40. He's streaming.
He's going nuts.
All right. Let's see here. Act one. Reading out Rialy's timestamps
here. Act one. Here's a clip of Zeus bothering Squeeze. You can
watch. You can hit watch fully
So Zeus is apparently just like being super like mad annoying
to people on this night.
Hell yeah.
He's just streaming. This is Squeeze Darius's roommate. Squeeze.
And then mid Korean man. Another I believe this guy lives with
him now, right?
This was the guy Spinboy saved. Yeah. Spinboy saved this guy
so hard that he lives with Darius now or lived with Darius until
he got kicked out. That is so saved. He is so saved. Bro, you
have to play a harder character. Dude, back away from my face,
Oh, really? Can you get out of my way, dude? You're being annoying,
bro. Get out of Get out of the face.
Dude, why did you just throw me across the room? What the aism,
guys? You guys are being
You guys are being agist against me because I'm old. I thought
you were Korean. Is that how they just take advantage of me and
throw me around? He's trying to He's basically like trying to
make these people do stuff with him. Trying to make content.
Trying to like bother people to
to get some content going to get like
Yeah. to get some content going, right? Okay. Going to another
timestamp here. Why is this not working? Why is kick broken?
Why is kick broken? Can we not? Can we not with the kick breaking
down thing? You want everyone in there by and
This is Zeus a little bit later in the They're pulling up right
now.
5 hours left. We've had a whole bunch. We've had a whole bunch
of people donate today. Okay. So, yeah, we're going long today.
We're going long. By the way, guys, you can still donate. I haven't
even chilled today. All right. I'm not even chilling at all.
Here, I should put exclamation point donate in the chat. I should
give you guys a kickbot TTS. Okay. Oh, whoops. Wrong thing. Wrong
thing. There's Kickbot. Big Korean man is currently staying there,
but he's not a permanent roommate. Okay, good update. Warning
there in the parking lot. Get Apparently him I got the feeling
that this Zeus guy was like constantly he was constantly doing
he's constantly doing bits and he was mad that people wouldn't
engage with him and do content with him, right? He's like, "Oh,
I live in a content house. Nobody wants to do I heard that comment
so you confronted
your shoes and what happened?"
Honestly, they should kick squeeze for not producing any content
that nontent uh wink.
Yeah. See, merc is going to go two ways. And if I'm
regret it the next day or two
sucking Darius all night while he laughs. Time for a smite. That's
right. They might mess with your truck. Watch
You would whip his ass. Okay, so this is um what? They're here.
Is this after they got kicked out? I don't know if Riyle's here
right now. This is after they got kicked out, right? Like not
kicked out, but I think Zeus and Murk left together, right? Mk
and Zeus were there and then they were hanging out because they
basically got asked to leave. What is the context? Oh yeah, Kelly.